Well, one week ago tonight,
an unarmed black man named George Floyd
was killed by a
Minneapolis police officer.
Every day since, people all over the world
have gathered to demand
change and call attention
to horrific racial injustices
affecting communities
of color every day.
Joining me tonight is Van Jones,
CNN's political commentator
and the CEO of Reform Alliance.
Thank you very much for being with us.
I said up front
that I don't wanna do
much talking tonight.
I'd rather you did the
talking so why don't we start,
what are you feeling
right now, how are you?
You know, I was as sad as I've ever been.
I think from a black
perspective as a parent,
we had this one little hope,
this little tiny thread
that there was something
we could tell our children
that they could do that
would keep them safe
from even the worst officers.
If they didn't run, if
they didn't talk back,
if they didn't have drugs on them,
if they didn't drive away,
if they kept their hands
on the steering wheel, if they
said, yes, sir or no, ma'am
that, we kinda sprinkled
this little fairy dust
on our kids every day about
how to survive, you know,
encounters with police.
In this situation, there's
nothing we could've told our kids
to survive, it was a lynching
from our point of view.
I mean, just literally, in broad daylight,
this guy just, you know,
one minute, two minute,
three minute, four minute,
five minute, six minute,
seven minutes with people
begging for this guy's life
and that brings back such
historical trauma for us
because that used to happen
a lot, just the lynching
of black men in public with
the community being helpless
and the lynchings were
designed to humiliate
and intimidate the whole community.
We can do whatever we want to you
and you can't do anything about it.
And when it's law enforcement
doing it, you really
feel helpless so that's why I
think you see this incredible
despair in the black community.
I think that's why you're
seeing this outpouring.
At the same time,
through our tears, we, I
think, might start to notice
that the fear that nobody cares about us,
that all the white people,
you know, don't understand,
may not be as well founded as we think
because there's 20, 30,
40, 50 million white people
who saw that video who were
also shocked and horrified
and are now saying, hey,
I might be late to the party
here but what can I do?
Now that is the positive.
You know, out of a breakdown
you can have a breakthrough
and there is a positive
side of this that nobody's
defending, I mean, you're not seeing,
you know, people may argue
about the disturbances
which we can talk about
but nobody is defending
what this officer did and it does create
some small bit of hope that's
starting to rise up in me
that we could have, at
least, a better conversation.
Look, you're never gonna
get rid of police brutality
just because, you'll never
get rid of bad schools
or bad restaurants, I mean,
you're always gonna have human
beings who just do bad
stuff but you can create
an environment where when
it happens the response
is effective enough that,
you know, other people
don't want to go down that same bad road.
You can close down, you
know, restaurants that are,
you know, not meeting the
sanitation requirement.
You can fire a teacher,
you can do certain things.
You're never gonna get rid of racism,
you're never gonna get
rid of police brutality
but you can have a better system
so that you don't have
lawlessness in law enforcement
then leading to lawlessness on the street,
that we can do.
It feels to me and again, I want,
you know, I wanna hear
how you're feeling
that there is an anger and
there's also a sense right now,
people are feeling very fragile,
there's almost a state of people
really being on the edge and
it's a mixture of feelings.
It's not just anger, it's
also, I mean, obviously
there's a lot of anger
out there and justifiably
so but it's more than that,
it's a little more complex
than that because this is not a new story.
This is not the first time it's happened
and in my lifetime, I mean,
I'm just a couple years old
when the first big riots hit
after Dr. Martin Luther King
is shot, there's a feeling
that we've been here again
and again and again and again.
Does this one feel different
to you for some reason?
I think it feels different
because there's literally
no excuse, like, all these other ones,
oh, well, he was running,
well, he was this, well,
he was talking back or
he punched a person,
or he was an ax murderer
or whatever it was.
I mean, this person, a $20 counterfeit?
You're gonna kill a guy
over a counterfeit $20 bill
that maybe wasn't even his
and it's in broad daylight
and everything that we have
said, well, let's get body cams.
They had body cams.
Yeah.
Well, let's, you know,
make sure community,
you know, people pay
attention, you know, bring out
the cell phones, all that
was done and the guy just sat
there with his hands in his pocket
while he was killing somebody,
so I think that the nature
of it is so much more
shocking, so much more visceral
and there's no excuse, you
can't point to a single thing.
After, listen, even after
minute two, it was justified,
after minute four,
five, six, seven, eight,
it wasn't, so--
Right.
So you're now in that world
and so and then I think
the other thing is that the,
when the local prosecutor
came forward and charged
only one of the officers
with third degree murder,
it's like, the most horrific
crime of the century
recorded for the whole world
and you get third degree
murder, I've never heard,
I'm an attorney, I've never
heard of third degree murder.
Yeah, can you do me a
favor and I know that
this is something that you've
studied, you are an attorney.
I didn't understand third
degree murder and my 14-year-old
son asked me last night,
"What's third degree murder?"
And I was embarrassed that I
didn't know and I didn't know
how that was even applicable,
it didn't make sense to me.
Yeah, third degree murder
is like a oopsy murder.
It's like, oops, it'd be
like, if you were driving past
a house that you thought was
empty and fired your weapon
and oops there was somebody
in there, like, the intention
was completely innocent but
you were maybe being reckless.
That's what that is, now
here's the problem with it.
Prosecutors don't behave
this way with everybody else.
Especially with black
people, with everybody else,
you'll get 27 charges and
everybody standing around
will also get arrested and
get at least 15 charges
so you have maximum number
of people, you know, arrested
'cause the standard for
arrest is probable cause,
I mean, you can arrest people
for practically nothing.
So everybody gets arrested
and everybody gets charged
with 1,000 things and then
you plead down from there.
When this local prosector
gives this cream puff charge
that nobody's ever heard of and
that's it and doesn't arrest
anyone else, what's he gonna
do, he's gonna plead down
to a traffic ticket, I
mean, you're starting
with third degree murder?
That's when the protests,
because everybody in the black
community, uh uh, this, the fix is in.
And that's when it got
worse not better because
of the nature of the charge.
Yeah.
Because it did feel, there
was also this lag time.
Everyone saw that horrible
video, it's completely
inexplicable and there
was this lag time that
before anything was
announced, anything was done
and you wonder might
things be different now
if immediately, people
had come forward and said,
no, this was wrong and here
are the steps we're gonna take,
an immediate investigation
and these people
are being placed under arrest.
Look, I think that you'd
have still had protests,
for sure, 'cause it was just so shocking.
You would've had protests but
it would've been a different
kind and you wouldn't have
had the level of exasperation
and frustration, I mean, you
still have the three other
officers not charged, the
reason you charge everybody
is because you get people
to turn on each other.
You know and probable cause
is such a low standard,
you can literally arrest
and charge everybody
and then you figure it
out, you have leverage
to figure it out, the idea
they don't even want leverage,
I mean, it's a complete
double standard and that's
again, so then it's salt
in the wound, like, nobody
would be treated this way.
If a white woman were being
treated this way by anybody,
it would be, I mean, the
entire block would've come out
and just tackled the guy,
I mean--
Yeah.
And so, and then the
prosecutor's behaving differently
as well, there is a way out of this.
You know, I think a lot of
people just feel total despair.
I don't think that that's
where we should stay.
I don't think we should deny the pain
but we shouldn't let the
pain have the last word.
There have been, you know,
there have been lynchings
in the past, there have
been bad cops in the past
and we've come through
that as a black community,
as an American community
and there's an opportunity
here, first of all, justice in
this case means all the cops
get charged, there's no way
that, you know, sitting around,
basically, an accessory to
murder, you should get away
scot-free, something needs to happen.
Number two, there can be now common ground
on this question of
lawlessness in law enforcement.
There could be a
bipartisan bill in Congress
that would do some smart
stuff, like, for instance,
one reason police officers act the way
that they do, you can't
sue 'em individually.
So they have literal, total immunity,
so no matter what happens,
maybe they get demoted or fired,
they still keep their house,
they still keep their boat,
they still keep their truck,
so there's a way that that
needs to be addressed, if
you do something egregious,
you should also be able
to have your personal
fortune at stake, that could be a break.
You wanna create checks
and balances and breaks on,
I'm from a law enforcement family.
My father was a cop in the military.
My uncle just retired from
Memphis City Police Force.
I understand, you know, cops aren't Satan,
they're not super heroes,
they're just city employees.
Some are good, some suck,
you gotta have systems
to deal with the ones that suck
and if you just say because
somebody has on a blue uniform,
I'm gonna back 'em no matter
what, that's not constitutional
democracy, that's gang
mentality, like, because
of what you're wearing,
I'm on your side, that's gang mentality.
We're not, the reason,
a democratic republic
trusts a small group of
armed men and now women
with a monopoly on violence, why?
Because there's checks, there's balances,
there's process, there's
laws, so we entrust you
with a monopoly on violence in a system.
Once you step out of that system
and you start abusing that,
if the system doesn't pull
you back, now you've just got
lawlessness of the worst kind.
You have, essentially, a number
of gangs in the community,
one of them just happens
to have on a badge.
That's not what you want
but that's what you've got
in way too many neighborhoods
and way too many cities
and right and left should
disagree with that reality.
Right and left should come
together and say, let's fix that.
Let's put some more tools in
place, put some more checks
and balances in place so
that you can have the police
obeying the law and therefore
the citizenry obeying the law
and that's how you have
peaceful streets and nobody
wants peaceful streets more,
nobody wants peaceful streets
more than African Americans,
we're not a part of some
pro riot lobby or some pro crime lobby.
I'm raising two black
boys here in Los Angeles,
I do not want riots here,
I just want lawful policing
and peaceful streets
just like everybody else.
Yeah, there's, I don't know how you react
to, this seems to happen whenever
there's an incident like this
and sadly, there are way too many of them,
you have people in the
white community saying
and I'm gonna say the white
liberal community saying,
I didn't realize, I didn't
quite realize the extent
and it feels a little bit
like we've expired on that,
you know, that the time
for people to be saying,
I didn't realize, well,
I didn't quite understand
how bad it was, I'm catching
up now, that we have past
that point quite a while ago
and that it's, there is no excuse.
Yeah, hey, listen,
I feel that way now, I do.
There's a fatigue,
this is just a fatigue.
You know, why do you pay
money to go to college?
Why do you pay tuition?
Because educating
somebody is costly, okay?
It's costly.
If I have to sit here and
educate every one of my white
friends every time something happens,
I have to educate one of my
white friends every Facebook
post from a high school
buddy, every well intentioned
colleague, it is costly and
they not paying me no tuition.
It's just a pure cost.
Right.
And at a certain point, you're
like, can you do your own
homework, can you just watch
the "13th" documentary?
Can you just read "The New Jim Crow?"
Just do a little bit so I don't
have to do all of it myself
every day and usually I'm
surrounded and outnumbered.
If you're a professional
black person, upper class
black person, frankly we're
only 12% of the country,
most of the time, you're
surrounded and outnumbered
and you're gonna have to
now try one more time,
create a free college for somebody else,
that, you know, you don't benefit from,
you actually are drained
by it, it's tough.
And you know, James
Baldwin said it the best.
He said, "When it comes to issues of race,
white people are always innocent."
They're always innocent
and their innocence
constitutes their crime.
How can you be innocent this
late, you know what I mean?
Quit being innocent, this
innocence act is now criminal.
Yeah.
Just admit
we live in a country
with a terrible history,
nobody likes that reality,
it's uncomfortable
but the fact that you can
run away from it, 364 days
out of the year doesn't mean you should.
It's just a part of being in a democratic,
multi-racial, multi-cultural,
multi-faith democracy,
we have to work to learn about each other
and if you're in the
majority, the whole country
conspires to make sure
you know your own history,
they call that American
history, you have to do a little
bit more work to learn the Latino history,
a little bit more work to
learn the black history,
learn the Eskimo history,
whatever you wanna call
it but that's the price
of being a good citizen in
a multi-racial democracy
and we're one of the few in
the history of the world.
It takes work and all that
work shouldn't just fall
on my shoulders to do the educating.
I think there was and I
think you've recently quoted
it but it was an interesting
quote, I think from Malcolm X,
that he was and you'll
correct me, you probably
know it better than I do
but I think he said he was
sometimes more afraid
of a liberal, you know,
someone who was well
intentioned but ignorant
than he was of an outright bigot
and felt that in a way that
could be more insidious.
Do you feel that that's something
that we might be experiencing right now?
Yeah, you know, I got
into a lot of trouble
earlier in the week, pointing
it out but, you know,
we're all friends here, at
some point we have to speak
honestly with each
other and there is a way
and Malcolm, you know, he
talked about the southern wolf
versus the northern fox, he
said, that southern wolf,
you know, he bares his
teeth at ya, and you know
he's mad at ya, you know
he doesn't want you around.
He said that northern fox, you know,
he might be smiling, looks
a little bit more friendly
but it's still, you know,
you're still in real danger
and so I do think we have
to look at the fact that
a lot of people who vote for
democrats, who support causes,
who share all the right
stuff on their Instagram page
and all that sort of stuff,
you know, to be honest,
don't have a lot of
personal black friends,
personal skin in the game,
don't hire a lot of African Americans,
don't have African American
lawyers or accountants
or dentists or you know, places
where the black community
does have a lot of
professionals stacked up,
they don't avail themselves
of those services.
They will call the cops
just like that woman
in Central Park, you know, in an instant
and you know, and act just like, I mean,
the Ku Klux Klan wouldn't
have acted any better
or any worse than that
white woman in Central Park
calling the police on that
black man for no reason and--
He was a bird watcher.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm really scared
of a bird watcher, you know,
in the park, so these
are the kinds of things,
there's a real opportunity
because if you're gonna be honest
and this is the worst
thing I'll say tonight.
If you're gonna be honest,
there is a way in which
white people choking off opportunity,
choking off dignity,
choking off the ability
to thrive and rise and
looking like they're not
doing anything wrong and
blaming the black people,
that's kind of America's
thing, it's a little bit
of our thing and when you
look in the face of that guy,
he looked like he wasn't
doing anything wrong,
he had his hands in his
pockets and he's literally
killing somebody and if
you ask him why, he'll say,
because this guy's a threat,
well, hold on a second.
You have to have a very
particular world view to look
at this picture and think the
guy down there is a threat
and that you're the innocent hero
and yet, we kinda do that, don't we?
Board room after board room,
hiring decision after hiring
decision, bank decision
after bank decision,
somehow, always the same
group gets choked out
and the other group benefits
and they're innocent
and so these are the kinds of
things that I would encourage
people to think about, is there some way
that I'm like that guy?
You know, am I kinda like that cop?
Would I overreact, am I afraid?
Am I giving enough oxygen?
To the black people in my community.
Do I have enough of the--
Awareness of the pain.
Do I have enough awareness
of the suffering?
Or am I looking away when
everybody else in the world
can see, man, that community's
suffering in your country.
Yeah, I think what you're pointing out
and which makes a lot of sense to me,
is it's very easy for people
to watch that footage,
that horrible footage,
demonize those officers,
say that's terrible, I feel
so terrible for you people
and I am on your side and it
can all feel like an empty
exercise, it can all feel
hollow and meaningless
as opposed to how did
we get to that point?
Right.
And what can we
do going forward, I'm curious,
I try to avoid the Trump of things
not for any other reason
that it can be such a big
distraction and I consider
it a victory when I have long
conversations with people
where he is not discussed
or he does not monopolize
the conversation.
Me too.
What could
a president do now today
that would be meaningful?
Let's forget for a moment that,
which president it is, what
could a president do today
that would be meaningful and be a salve
to the African American community,
make them feel better
and make them feel like
they were heard, what would it take?
Well, you know, ironically, some of things
that Trump is actually doing, ironically.
You know, have the Department of Justice
and the FBI get in there and figure out
what the heck is going on.
That has been done and is being done.
You know, receive a briefing
directly in the oval office
about it and then speak out
publicly which he also did.
The situation that we're in,
is it's the things that he
should stop doing that cause the problems.
The tweeting and this sort of stuff
but there, you know, I'm trying
to be fair with everybody,
there have been things that
the Trump administration
has done that are appropriate.
He should stop doing certain
things and then beyond
what has been done.
You know, we need to get together.
We need to come together.
If we don't come together,
we're gonna end up
where we're headed and where
we're headed is not good.
You could have, we're about
one more of these video tapes
away from having, you know,
five or six American cities
burned to the ground, I mean,
this is not a good trajectory
to be on as a country and
nobody would like that outcome.
So we have an outcome that's
looming that nobody wants,
you can get everybody together.
Man, would it be great for everybody
to go to the white house.
Everybody, NAACP, the NRA,
I mean, everybody just
go to the white house
and just sit down and just cry
and just have some ministers
come and pray over everybody
and for secular people, you
know, have some musicians come
and just have a big cry
and then
listen to law enforcement say
how they don't like what's
going on and they're
willing to make some changes
because obviously, something's
going on that they don't want
and listen to some of those
young kids talk about how,
I mean, those kids are so heartbreaking.
I just wanna be able to
go to a white neighborhood
and not feel afraid, I mean simple things
and just get together,
that's what I would like.
Just get together, this is, you know,
when the funeral happens, I
mean, wouldn't it be amazing
if all the republican leaders
and all the democrat leaders
were sittin' in there, I
mean, I guess we gotta social
distance or whatever but, you know,
whatever it is, this is
a time to say, listen,
I can score points and
you can score points.
I can call you a racist and
you can call me a socialist.
I can say you you're Antifa,
you can say I'm a Nazi.
I mean we can do this, we've
been doing this now for years
but this one, you gotta
draw a circle around
and Americans are drawing
a circle around it.
I mean, the disturbances, that's different
but this particular murder,
Americans have drawn a circle
around, there is room now,
I think, for a president
to bring everybody together.
I wanna make sure I
mention, Reform Alliance,
this is something, you're
the CEO of Reform Alliance
and talk about taking action
to move the puzzle piece
a little forward, tell us what it is.
Well, you know, Jay-Z and
Meek Mill and Robert Smith
and Robert Kraft and a
bunch of billionaires
including Clara Wu Tsai
and Novogratz and Dan Loeb
and Laura Arnold, all got together
a year and a half ago and said
too many are going to jail
for petty stuff and too
many people are caught up
on probation and parole for
too long and they're going back
to jail for petty stuff, let's
do something to try to have
fewer people going to jail for petty stuff
and 'cause you shouldn't
deprive people of their liberty
lightly and then between the COVID thing
which has now made the
jails full of this plague
and people are dying in
the prisons in huge numbers
and then this incident,
we realize, we are also,
we're not just trying to protect liberty,
we're trying to protect people's lives
and we partnered with
Jack Dorsey from Twitter
to get masks into all
the jails and prisons.
We have legislation moving
in a number of states
to try to reduce the number
of people going to jail
for probation and parole
violations, little non-crime
technical violations, a
lot of things like that
but this thing set us on our butt
and Jay-Z himself picked
up the phone and called
the governor of Minnesota
and asked him personally
to make sure that the case
was given to the state
attorney general, who happens
to be African American
but is also just a fair minded prosecutor
so that it wouldn't, we
wouldn't keep going down
this road of having the local
prosecutor screw up the case
and then people burn down the country
and thankfully for that
reason and many others,
the governor did give the
case to a better prosecutor.
So when you have a
better chance of justice,
I think you have a better
chance of a bipartisan bill
that could really fix law
enforcement in some important ways
and there also needs to
be a better chance to try
to put some money into these communities.
All these corporations and
banks should get together,
let's help these communities,
we see what's going on.
If you have justice, legislation,
and economic opportunity,
we can come out of this
stronger and better
and that's, I'm starting to
feel some hope now for that,
I'm starting to feel some hope.
You know, we didn't really
even get much of a chance
to talk before we hooked up on Zoom today
and so I wasn't sure
what your state of mind
was gonna be and again, I
wanted you to do the talking
and I'm hearing pain and I'm
hearing anguish and frustration
but I'm also hearing some
hope that there might
be an opportunity here
and I wanna be careful
when I say that and I'm
saying there's an opportunity
in a horrible situation but
there might be an opportunity
here to move ahead, to move
up and to be a little better.
I think so, I think if
people don't stop at pity
because pity burns out,
it doesn't feel good.
If we move to opportunity, if
we move to say, hey, listen,
who knows, I mean, that
guy that got killed,
he might have cured
cancer for all we know,
we don't who the heck that
guy was or what his kids
could've become or whatever.
Right, right.
So we're wasting
some genius, we're missing out
on some possible best friends
we ever had and some possible
great employees or employers
or contractors or neighbors.
What can I do in my personal life?
People go, how can I fix
the police department?
Trust me, that's not easy
but your own workplace,
you might be able to get an
internship program in place,
you might be able to mentor somebody.
Don't forget how much you
know and not from a book.
How much you know
because somebody sat down
and talked to you.
One of the problems when
you're black is it's hard
to find a person who'll
talk to you, honestly.
You know, the conversation
gets stiff or tense
or whatever or it just
doesn't happen because
you don't even know that that
building you're driving past
is a lodge or a country
club, it's just a building,
you've never been invited in
there and so are there people
you can mentor, the people
who, and the thing about
mentorship is you always
get more out of it then you
give anyway, it's not charity,
you wind up so much smarter
and so much more interesting,
you know, oh, I'm talkin'
to my kid from the other side of town
and now you're the most
interesting person at Thanksgiving.
You know, so you always
get more than you give
but those are the things that
I would ask people to do.
We have to change some
laws but I tell you what,
if we start changing
who's in our phone book,
who's in our cell phone,
who are we texting with
every couple of days, who
we, that's really where
the change has got to start
happening because then,
you know, suddenly, you
know, somebody says something
in a conversation, and
say, hey, hold on a second,
that's not funny, I know a guy who's black
and I've learned the hard
way, that can wind up
killing somebody and people
are, what, we didn't know
that you were feeling that way,
well, I do feel that way now
and suddenly you start
wiping this stuff out
at the social level long before
it ever gets to the legal
level and I think that's important.
Well, I cannot thank you enough
for doing this today.
I've always loved talking
to you in the past,
we've had really good conversations
and I did not wanna hear my voice today.
I was really happy that it
could be your voice, so--
Hey, listen, you've
always been good to me,
you know, every time I've
had a show launch or a book,
you've always had me on and
you know, I'm glad it created
a friendship between us and
now we can use it to try
to bring a little bit of hope to people
and I'll come back anytime
you'll have me, sir.
Thank you so much, this
was very meaningful to me
and I, stay well and good luck
with your kids and handling
all of this and let's keep
the conversation going.
Will do, thank you very much.
Thank you, sir.